what is up everybody its Anna Mack here
for anime uproar and today I will be
talking about the latest stunning
developments in the black clover story
including some extremely important
things that we have learned in recent
chapters in the midst of the current
epic battle that is taking place in the
story
many of us have overlooked some
game-changing information that has been
revealed to us in this current arc in
particular and I believe that these
shocking revelations deserve a lot more
attention because they could prove to be
crucial hints for where the story will
go from here and for who will be the
future villains in the black clover
series
I can't wait to delve deep into all the
hidden twists and turns in the story so
let's do this if you enjoyed the black
clover content on this channel and you
want to see more you can leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to anime
uproar over get subscribe and hit that
notification bell and of course I will
be dealing with the latest developments
in the black clover story so manga
spoilers ahead you have been warned we
recently learned a lick transformed into
the giant demon in order to prevent the
devil from possessing his body if the
devil had succeeded in taking licks body
light magic would no longer have been
effective on him and this means that
even Lumiere could not have defeated him
so in order to stop the devil from
taking over licked chose to transform
knowing full well that this would mean
his death at the hands of Lumiere and
that was all part of licks desperate
plan he wanted Lumiere to kill him after
he transformed so that he could not go
on destroying the clover kingdom and
killing innocent people it is clear that
this demonic transformation made Licht
go berserk and he had almost no control
so unless Lumiere stopped him he would
have potentially gone on to destroy the
entire kingdom
however we recently learned that Lumiere
was only able to defeat licked in his
giant demon form because licked was able
to regain control of his body and stop
himself for long enough for Lumiere to
use light magic to kill him
licks actions here speak to his strength
and determination as a character not
only was lift willing to sacrifice his
own humanity and his own life to stop
the devil from incarnated into this
world but he was also strong enough to
regain control of himself even in his
giant demon form for long enough to make
Lumiere's victory possible in spite of
the agonizing despair delict had just
gone through at his own wedding ceremony
and despite losing his own pregnant wife
before his very eyes
lect was able to see the situation
clearly he sada Lumiere had not betrayed
him he saw through the devil's plan and
he was able to sacrifice himself for the
greater good
Licht is truly a character worthy of the
highest praise and respect
and speaking of sacrificing one's
humanity we recently learned that during
that same epic battle from 500 years ago
sacré also known as Nero grew black
horns on her head because she used
forbidden magic including the magic
stones in order to boost her sealing
magic so that she could imprison in the
devil at this point when the devil sees
that his plants have been thoroughly
foiled for the time being he decides to
use reincarnation magic to initiate the
elf reincarnation spell but he makes
sure that the spell will be initiated
500 years in the future long after
Lumiere and sakra have died and can no
longer pose a threat to the devil but
Sacre refuses to take this lying down
and she uses her magic to seal Lumiere
away because she knows that the seal she
put on the devil won't hold forever and
this leads to her using up too much
magic and it causes her to lose her
humanity transforming her into the anti
bird that we all know as Nero and with
this we finally learned the full
backstory of Nero and back in the
present
sacré is able to use her unique magic to
fully awaken licked in his artificial
body up until this point Licht had only
been partially awake but thanks to
Lumiere's help and training his Sacre's
magic was able to improve and develop
until she was able to not only seal and
unseal objects but she is also able to
unseal the inner essence of Licht
allowing him to finally be reunited with
his friend Lumiere upon his awakening
lifts greets his old friends and then he
speaks to Patri he explains to Patri how
Lumiere killed him and his demon
transformation in
to stop him from killing innocent people
and eventually people like hasta you
know and the others managed to stop
Patri from killing innocent people as
well lick says that even though the
terrible thinks Patri has done cannot be
taken back the thing that matters the
most now is standing together against an
ancient evil that wants to plunge the
entire world into suffering and chaos
and that ancient evil is of course
everyone's favorite horny villain the
devil and then finally an epic team
battle ensues as Lumiere licked and
sacrifice off against the devil and
ultimately even hasta joins the fray
propelled by you know hasta rushes at
the devil giving the villain a taste of
his powerful anti magic sword and this
concept of anti magic which for some
reason is resistant to the devil's
otherworldly magic really made me think
about the story so far and where it
could be heading next a lot of people
have been speculating that hasta Santa
magic could be enough to destroy the
devil but I think that while hasta may
play an important role in eventually
defeating the devil he won't be able to
accomplish it alone after all this is
the genius of black clover and its power
system the protagonist doesn't just
defeat the villain all on his own when
he gets mad enough or when the power of
friendship within him is strong enough
in black clover we can see that the
protagonists like Austin you know are
overpowered in a number of ways but they
are not so overpowered that they can
simply defeat a major villain like the
devil all on their own instead Austin
you don't have to work together and
fight as a team with other overpowered
characters including Yami and the other
magic Knights and in this particular
battle they are fighting alongside
potentially the strongest human in
history Lumiere and the strongest of the
elf tribe licked I personally love this
aspect of black clover the epic team
battles that require many powerful magic
abilities of different types to all work
together in strategic ways is what makes
the fights in black clovers so
interesting and another extremely
interesting concept that we have been
introduced to in this latest arc of the
black horse story is the existence of
other worlds / realms / dimensions let's
look at all the information that we have
about the other world / the other
dimension that the
supposedly comes from we saw that in the
shadow palace magic stones allow want to
draw what they desire from the
underworld the devil is able to draw his
body from the other world in order to
incarnate fully into this world when he
does this
the elf aronia whom the devil was
possessing says welcome back as if the
devil's body may have been in this world
at some point in the past the devil goes
on to say that he finally has a body for
the first time in centuries and he
proclaims that it is good to be back
since we know from the flashbacks that
the devil did not have his own body 500
years ago when he orchestrated the elf
massacre we are left to wonder whether
at some point even further in the past
the devil had been in this world with
his own body and then somehow at some
point he ended up losing his body
perhaps he was defeated by elves and
humans who lived even before licked and
Lumiere the fact is that this
otherworldly overpowered creature known
as the devil is still a massive mystery
to us we know what he did to the elves
in tatty of 500 years ago but we have no
idea how the devil came to this world
what his true origins are how he lost
his original body and so on what we do
know is that once he appears the devil
immediately senses the demon inside of
us as grimoire referring to austin's
demon the devil says that other devil is
it resonating with my magic the
overflowing anti magic is erasing the
magic around him the devil proceeds to
call Asta's demon a meddlesome comrade
who dwells in the grimoire which I
should have possessed this tells us that
despite apparently being from another
world the devil is not a unique creature
the demon inside of us has grimoire is
its comrade meaning that there are
potentially more devils and demons out
there but how exactly did they get here
and why are they here
we know that the devil needed both a
body and a five leaf grimoire in order
to manifest his true power and his true
form in this world we also know that it
was this devil who created the grimoire
of despair that a standout possesses but
we don't know how the other devil the
demon currently inhabiting Asta's
grimoire got there in the first place
what we do know is that when the devil
uses his magic to attack hasta
magic flows out of asses body and
protects him and the same happens with
Patriot Act's hasta in his Dark Elf form
it seems clear that the demon inside of
us as grimoire is protecting hasta and
also protecting himself in the process
at one point the devil speaks directly
to the demon inside of Asta's grimoire
and tells him that if he doesn't steal
asked his body soon he will die along
side hasta and if this is true it makes
sense that the demon would want to
protect hasta and himself there are
several possibilities for how Asta's
demon God inside of lake's former
grimoire one possibility is that the
demonic part of licked that dark part of
him which became the giant demon after
he transformed turned into a new demonic
entity separate from lick and was
trapped in the 5-leaf grimoire if that
is the case then demons or Devils are
created when someone succumbs to despair
and completely loses their humanity
which could mean that the devil who is
the current main villain was at some
point many centuries ago a human on elf
or some other normal species but he
became the devil after succumbing to
despair however the other possibility
and definitely one that has been hinted
at more is that there is an entire other
world or other dimension out there that
might be full of demons slash Devils in
this recent art we have gone a ton of
clues above this other world chapter 2
of 2 of the manga is called from another
world and in this same chapter the devil
makes a reference to our dimension of
origin when speaking about the demons
pot she also calls the devil's dark
magic magic from the other world and in
Chapter 203 the newly awakened Lumiere
immediately identifies the devil's magic
as magic that is not of this world
in Chapter 204 Lumiere confirms that the
devil is a being from another world and
there is another important clue about
the nature of this Otherworld hidden in
the concept of the ten apostle's of
Saphira both visually in terms of
symbols and linguistically in terms of
their name the apostle's of Saphira are
a reference to the sefirot which refers
to the 10 attributes or emanations in
the kabbalah through which the infinite
reveals itself and continuously creates
both the physical realm and a chain of
higher metaphysical realms
this part about the chain of higher
metaphysical realms is important these
references to Sephiroth coupled with all
the clues about another world or
dimension where the devil comes from are
a clear indication that other realms
exist beyond the mortal realm in which
the current black clover story is taking
place ever since the devil has been
introduced to the story I have been
wondering where the story could possibly
go from here the devil is so overpowered
and his kotodama magic is so broken that
at first it seemed like no other villain
could ever compare to him in the future
where does the story go after such an
epic LP villain I think that the answer
lies within these alternate realms which
exist alongside the mortal realm
assuming that the devil is right and
both he and austin's demon have a
different dimension of origin we can
assume that there are other demons and
possibly even more powerful creatures in
happening that other dimension the
current devil that everyone is fighting
could be just one of hundreds or even
thousands of devils and demons to
inhabit that other realm and what's more
for all we know this devil could be one
of the weakest of his entire race I do
wonder why this particular devil is so
interested in incarnated into this world
is there something going on in his home
dimension that made it necessary for him
to flee and come to this world and if so
what could be so bad to drive a creature
as powerful as the devil to escape into
another dimension on top of that if we
know that at least two different
dimensions or realms exist who's to say
that there couldn't be even more realms
or dimensions out there and with each
new realm or dimension there are
possibilities for introducing new
powerful creatures including new opie
villains that can keep the story going
for hundreds of chapters to come this
introduction of new realms and
dimensions really opens up the world of
black clover to infinite possibilities
and even though the current arch villain
known as the devil is incredibly Opie
with the prospect of alternate realms
and dimensions the possibilities for new
villains and new story developments are
endless one thing is for sure the Devils
kotodama magic as absolutely broken as
it is does have its limitations it can't
block Yami's dark magic so the devil has
to
instead and hasta can't be swallowed by
the devil's magic his own lack of magic
ability and his unique anti magic power
makes him resistant to the devil's dark
magic even though the devil's magic
comes from another dimension in Chapter
205 the devil says that hasta Santa
magic is even more annoying than he
thought at first which means that hasta
Santa magic and its connection to the
demon inside his grimoire will prove
crucial and ultimately defeating the
devil and unlocking the secrets of the
other realms as the epic battle between
the devil and pretty much everyone else
continues I'm extremely curious to see
what happens next
personally I can't wait to find out more
about the world of black clover and
about the realms and dimensions that lie
beyond that world but what do you guys
think why did the devil abandon his own
dimension in order to incarnate into
this world
what is his dimension of origin like and
do you think that it could be home to
creatures that make this devil look like
child's play also how do you think that
the demon inside of Austin's grimoire
got there in the first place and what do
you think that Auster's demon actually
wants finally who do you think will be
the next villain after the epically
overpowered devil let me know down in
the comments if you enjoyed the black
clover content on this channel and you
want to see more you can leave a like to
let me know and if you're new to the
channel don't forget to subscribe and
hit that notification bell if you'd like
to support more content on the channel
and get some epic anime merch check out
our online store anime out Broadcom we
have original designs that were done
exclusively for us by pro manga artist
Cuusoo mati including this dream big
work hard hasta shirt for your fan of
the channel feel free to use the
discount code uproar 25 at checkout for
an instant 25% off a huge thank you to
all of our anime uproar patrons for
supporting our work
I wanna especially thank our pro hero to
your patrons the one and only gilgamesh
baby Rey and chubs is the man and
another huge thank you to our the one to
your patrons the ones who stand above
all other clans
ace Maddy Mac James a Lola Madame Ingrid
ah and a mod if you guys feel that our
content provides value for you and you
want to support more be sure to check
out our patreon link in the description
even donating a single dollar will give
you access to our anime up for patron
exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us space cowboys
[Music]